Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Frittlav und hier ist sie, die zweiundvierzigste Ausgabe Hurra, zweiundvierzig äh.
Wow.
Worin wir finden werden, alle Antworten auf alle Fragen, die jemals gestellt wurden.
Wir liefern euch die Antworten und die Fragen dazu müsst ihr euch dann selber ausdenken.
Genau, so läuft das.
So, heute ist Corona Wiekli äh natürlich mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Jetzt auch wieder richtig Wikli, weil jetzt passiert ja wenigstens was, ne?
Ja, ja, ja.
Man braucht ja jetzt ein Hobby für die nächste Zeit. Nehmen wir doch einfach die alten Hobbys. Sehr viele andere bleiben einem ja nicht übrig. Ja.
Also gewünscht hätte ich mehr was anderes.
Ja ich auch, hätten wir uns glaube ich alle was anderes gewünscht, aber irgendwie ist es dazu nicht gekommen. Man kann zumindest sagen, Tokyo Soul, aber das bringt einen ja dann irgendwie auch nicht durch den Tag.
Nee, nee. Nee, ich hätte lieber Unrecht behalten.
Ja. Ähm vielleicht zum Start noch ein kleines bisschen äh Feedback äh exemplarisch,
ein Kommentar von Timo, hallo Pavel, hallo Tim. Ähm vielen Dank für eure Arbeit bei der Aufzählung von Pavel zu den Berufen, die einem,
die bei einem zweiwöchigen Lokdown nicht zu Hause bleiben können, habe ich die Berufsgruppe der Sozialarbeitenden vermisst, wie eigentlich in fast allen Aufzählungen seit März. Ich bin selber Sozialarbeiter daher, meine persönliche Betroffenheit
gibt so viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die nicht einfach zu Hause bleiben können in der Jugendhilfe, stationär wie auch ambulant und im Jugendamt beim Kinder und Jugendgesundheitsdienst auch im Krankenhaus, Frauenhäuser, Obdachlosenarbeit
et cetera. Es wäre möglich, dass sich die Menschen mit Lebensmitteln eindecken, allerdings eine Wohngruppe mit Kindern, die nicht bei ihren Eltern leben können, muss vierundzwanzig sieben besetzt sein.
Mahlzeit, wenn die Kollegin vierzehn Tage lang mit zehn Kindern den Alltag ohne das Haus zu verlassen bewältigen soll. Leider wird unsere Berufsgruppe häufig nicht in ihrer Relevanz für die Gesellschaft wahrgenommen.
Ja also,
Klar. Wir wollten auch, glaube ich, hier äh erstmal, wenn du anfängst, irgendwelche Berufsgruppen aufzuzählen, dann fehlen eine ganze Menge anderer und,
glaube, wenn man noch ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt, fallen einem auch noch eine Menge an die ähnlicher Art und Weise,
anders, dann äh auch extrem betroffen sind, ist vollkommen klar. Ich denke so, hast du's ja auch nicht auch nicht gemeint, ne?
Und natürlich ist es dann im Detail alles äh super viel äh schwieriger und komplizierter äh so als man denkt, äh so ein so ein Schuttlaun, aber,
die Grundidee sag ich mal ist dann schon, dass man doch sehr sehr weit gehen kann eigentlich. Ähm.
Ja äh Timo hat, das werden wir dann aber auch nochmal erwähnen. Ähm Timo hat äh eine Kampagne ins Leben gerufen, die wollen wir natürlich dann hier nicht vergessen,
dauerhaft systemrelevant, dauerhaft Strichsystemrelevant Punkt DE und da geht's genau um die Ursache Unterstützung für Sozialarbeitende.
Ja, trotzdem wollen wir uns heute natürlich wie immer und mehr denn je äh auf die Zahlen stürzen.
Ja und die Zahlen sind äh unerfreulich. So, wir haben halt,
Jetzt in.
In der letzten Woche ja ein Rekord nach dem anderen erlebt bei den Neuinfektionen in Deutschland und auch der,
sieben Tage Schnitt bei den Neuinfektionen hat praktisch jeden Tag neue Höhen
erreicht und ja, wir sind jetzt so bei äh knapp vierzehntausend pro Tag im.
Schnitt der letzten sieben Tage so und heute waren's fast neunzehntausend neu.
Wir haben natürlich auch immer noch eine Dunkelziffer
ich hab jetzt kürzlich die Zahl von drei gehört so das würde dann bedeuten dass ich real tatsächlich heute oder beziehungsweise äh ja an einem.
In den letzten Tagen so über fünfzigtausend Menschen angesteckt haben und das ist halt,
schon ja bedenklich. Und äh noch bedenklicher ist halt äh ja wie steil die Kurve.
Einfach ist so die seit teilweise steiler als im,
April beziehungsweise im März äh die die Kurve als wir die erste Welle hatten,
stellt die auch mittlerweile in den Schatten und also mittlerweile haben wir wahrscheinlich auch real, wenn man berücksichtigt, dass damals die Dunkelziffer wahrscheinlich deutlich höher war,
kann man sagen, sind wir jetzt gerade da, wo wir auf dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle waren. So ungefähr kann man das.
Einschätzen.
Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, waren wir zum Höhepunkt dieser Wähler äh dieser ersten Welle waren schon Maßnahmen beschlossen und in Kraft gesetzt worden.
Ja, wir waren als der Höhepunkt äh so jetzt, was den sieben Tagesschnitt äh angeht, war so am fünften April,
und da waren wir schon fast zwei Wochen im Logdown eigentlich. Ähm ja.
Also insofern äh wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass eigentlich der Lokdown jetzt erst am Montag beginnt
steht uns in den nächsten zwei Wochen ja noch ein bisschen was bevor, mindestens.
Oh, ich habe natürlich wieder äh standesgemäß vergessen, das Datum zu nennen. Wir nehmen auf am dreißigsten,
zwanzig zwanzig. Montag ist also dann der zweite November, der offizielle Starttag für neue Maßnahmen
eingeschränkten Maße kann man natürlich davon ausgehen, dass diese Verkündung, diese dieser Maßnahmen,
im besten Fall auch schon eine leichte Veränderung des Verhaltens nach sich zieht. Allerdings, das werden wir sicherlich dann äh nachher nochmal besprechen, wenn wir durch die Maßnahmen selber durchgehen.
Mit Einschränkungen, weil ich glaube, auf der einen Seite ist der Schockfaktor natürlich nicht der selbe. Ne, also wir hatten ja im März dieses.
Oh mein Gott, was kommt da? Ja, wo wo man,
jede Begegnung auf der Straße, wie, wo man den Leuten so auf fünf Metern ausgewichen ist, weil man einfach gar keinerlei belastbare Informationen hatte.
Um diese Gefahr einzuschätzen, was teilweise natürlich für zu einer.
Also was, glaube ich, auch in beide Richtungen ausschlägt, ne, dass manche Leute übervorsichtig waren
und andere halt einfach noch nicht ausreichend. Das wird man dann, glaube ich, erst im Nachgang äh sehen, wie sich das dazu verhält, aber auf jeden Fall sind wir jetzt hinterher und stehen eigentlich erst am Anfang der Eindämmung.
Und,
das heißt, dass wir uns so wahrscheinlich jetzt noch auf zwei Wochen täglich äh steigende Neuinfektionen einstellen können und,
bei dem bei der Reproduktionszahl, die wir im Moment haben, nämlich so um die eins Komma vier
sich äh die Zahlen vielleicht noch vervierfachen können, dass wir vielleicht in die Größenordnung von ja
sechzig, siebzigtausend, neun Fällen pro Tag kommen.
Ist ja sogar ein äh wahrscheinliches Szenario, dass das in diese Höhen geht.
Und dann sehen wir halt leider, also zumindest in Berlin habe ich mir das angeschaut,
ja das mittlerweile auch die Infektion wieder in die Altersgruppe der über achtzigjährigen,
übergeschwappt ist, also es gibt wohl Ausbrüche in Berlin in mehreren Altersheimen und Berlin ist halt jetzt die Gruppe der über achtzigjährigen, die mit der zweithöchsten Instit
So aktuell nach den.
Fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen. Ähm ja und das,
wiederum führt dazu, dass wir zwangsläufig ähm.
Mehr Leute in den Krankenhäusern äh haben werden. In Berlin gibt's jetzt so Meldungen. Das Jahr in zwei bis vier Wochen jetzt, wenn das so weitergeht
die Intensivstation voll sind, so dass uns also wer zu sagen zwei bis vier Wochen
ist beim gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt so die Kapazitätsgrenze erreicht in Berlin.
Das wird also eng äh äh werden, absehbar und äh ja, wir können halt leider jetzt so in den letzten zwei Wochen bereits einen Anstieg
der Sterbezahlen sehen in Deutschland. Ist zwar.
Noch nicht jetzt super dramatisch und noch nicht auf dem längst nicht auf dem Niveau von,
April, aber es steht jetzt zu befürchten, dass wir die Aprilzahlen nochmal übertreffen äh werden, möglicherweise deutlich.
Was waren die Aprilzahlen in ihrem Maximum?
Ja, der sieben im im Sieben-Tagesschnitt so zweihundertfünfzig pro Tag und wir sind jetzt ungefähr bei fünfzig.
Also man kann sagen, ja dass wahrscheinlich jetzt ja tausend.
Zweitausend, dreitausend Leute jetzt in den nächsten zwei Monaten ungefähr sterben werden.
Das lässt sich jetzt nicht mehr vermeiden, ja? Das ist der Drops ist gelutscht. So, hm,
und,
Es ist halt die andere Sache, wenn man jetzt die Kurve betrachtet, so, was einem dann klar hinterher sind natürlich alle schlauer, so hinterher ist man natürlich schlauer, aber kann nachgucken, ja.
Es hat sich halt abgezeichnet, hat sich halt seit langem abgezeichnet so. Idealerweise hätten wir.
Im Ende Juli oder spätestens im August äh als.
Gesehen haben, dass die Zahlen ständig nach oben marschieren, so hätte man schon mal was tun müssen. Gut,
fallen eher nur langsamer Anstieg, aber die Zahlen haben sich immerhin verdreifacht in einem Monat, ja? Das ist dann auch nicht so
wäre ganz ohne, da hätte man eigentlich äh äh schon mal was tun müssen. Gut, nichts passiert. Dann,
Ähm ja ging's weiter in,
den September und Anfang September sind da nochmal fünfzig Prozent dazu gekommen, so. Ja und das.
War klar, die Zahlen marschieren halt nach oben. Gleichzeitig explodiertes schon richtig in den Nachbarländern
So, das heißt, wir hatten im Prinzip zwei Indikatoren, einmal unsere eigenen Zahlen und dann äh ja, so ein bisschen
Preview sogar durch die Nachbarländer, wo äh es äh ein bisschen früher losgegangen ist, bauten zu
Ja und dann haben wir ungefähr nochmal vier Wochen vergehen lassen bis jetzt.
Neue Maßnahmen ergriffen wurden und das ist, ich sage mal, bei.
Also mindestens zwei Wochen zu spät eigentlich vier Wochen zu spät, ja?
Was jetzt am Montag kommt und ja, weil wir haben ja noch Zeit und uns dann irgendwie sich auch noch vorbereiten. So hat man dann eben auch noch ein paar Tage gewartet, wo jetzt eigentlich jeder Tag tatsächlich zählt.
Das ist halt so auch das Ding. Aber ja und dann kommt natürlich jetzt noch dazu.
Schon mal dabei sind, wie es jetzt äh wahrscheinlich weitergeht. Ähm.
Wie schnell kriegen wir das jetzt abgebremst so in Tschechien.
Und in Belgien kann man jetzt sehen, da greifen die Maßnahmen jetzt, in Israel hat's auch so gegriffen, je nachdem nur nach zwei Wochen ungefähr äh
war er dann der Anstieg gestoppt und dann nach vier Wochen kommt man einen deutlichen Abwärtstrend sehen. So
Das waren aber zum Teil nochmal deutlich härtere Maßnahmen, die
da ergriffen wurden beziehungsweise hat man auch erstmal angefangen so wie bei uns und hat dann nochmal einen draufgelegt, deswegen erwarte ich jetzt, weil ich meine bei uns,
äh
bleiben die Schulen offen, bleiben die Kindergärten offen und die Kirchen bleiben offen. Zum Beispiel interessanterweise und äh ja, dass,
und die Friseure, ja. Das alles sorgt natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht dafür äh zumindest, dass.
Schneller zum Stehen kommt, sondern im Zweifelsfall
verlängert es halt jetzt den Logdown, also es ist halt auch so eine Regel, je härter man auf die Bremse tritt äh so, umso kürzer der Bremsweg. So und wenn man halt nur so halb auf die Bremse trit
dann dauert's halt länger. So und in der Situation sind wir jetzt gerade und so
meine Vermutung ist, obwohl alle wissen, dass jetzt die nächsten vierzehn Tage wahrscheinlich nicht viel passieren wird, sondern die Zahlen nach oben gehen, wird natürlich die Panik
massiv steigen und kann sein, dass man wie auch bei der ersten Welle dann man nochmal nachlegen wird in,
ein, zwei Wochen, weil äh ja, Panik aufkommt. Ja ähm das.
Vielleicht mal vorne vorne weg. So konkreter noch ähm.
Mal jetzt in die Länder auch guckt. Ja, Bremen, NRW und Hessen,
liegen jetzt vor Berlin und Hamburg in meine Risikotabelle
Es gibt nur noch zwei Bundesländer, Schleswig-Holstein und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, die keine Risikoländer sind und noch unter fünfzig Neuinfektionen pro hunderttausend
Einwohnern liegen. Ja, ansonsten, was man so wiederum durchnimm,
Blick in die Top dreißig äh ganz gut erkennt ist, dass irgendwie das Ruhrgebiet in Flammen steht. Ähm ja, anders kann man das immer nicht so gesehen habe,
jetzt ja in den Top dreißig,
Bottrop, Dortmund, Offenbach, Herne, Solingen, Remscheid.
Wuppertal ja also Bochum Köln ähm ja also.
Das Ruhrgebiet auch Sauerland und drum her.
Ja also Ruhrgebiet und Rheinland und äh aber speziell ja Ruhrgebiet, wie gesagt, die Gegend um Duisburg, Dortmund und so Bottrop, das Dreieck irgendwie.
Müssen wir sofort ein Beherberungsverbot ausrufen. Gut, das haben wir jetzt eh alle.
Aber ansonsten Spitzenreiter, also NRW ist mit elf Landkreisen in der.
In den Top dreißig vertreten, aber Bayern ist äh auch wieder gut dabei mit
wieder acht Landkreisen während Berlin rausgefallen ist weitgehend und nur noch mit Friedrichshain Kreuzberg vertreten ist momentan.
In der Risikol.
Was aber nicht daran liegt, dass es jetzt irgendwie das Infektionsgeschehen stark eingedämmt worden wäre, sondern nur, dass die anderen schneller vorbeiziehen. Das muss man natürlich äh an der Stelle auch mal sagen, ne.
Ja ganz genau, das ist äh wichtig, also überall.
Berlin sind halt jetzt alle Bezirke super rot, also alle Bezirke über fünfzig.
Westen steht noch Treptow-Köpenick da mit neunundsiebzig Komma drei.
Im Moment und dann geht's halt hoch bis zweihundertachtundsechzig in Neukölln.
Aber in Neukölln steigen die Zahlen langsamer als äh.
In Friedrichshain Kreuzberg. Ja und was man noch sagen muss zu den Bundesländern.
Allen Bundesländern steigen die Zahlen, ja. Aber in Berlin interessanterweise am langsamsten von allen Bundesländern.
Das kann sich nur um einen Zufall handeln.
Ja oder wir sind halt wieder derzeit ein bisschen voraus, wer weiß, vielleicht äh.
Die Selbstliebe stirbt zuletzt.
Also ich bin äh äh gestern mal hier durch die Straßen äh gegangen und habe mal so ein bisschen in Restaurants und Kneipen reingeschaut und äh habe jede Hoffnung verloren, dass dass äh,
irgendetwas anderes hilft als einfach knallhart dicht machen. Ist einfach man kriegt den Leuten nicht.
Besucht die Läden, teilweise saßen Leute sogar draußen, so,
hier in Pankow jedenfalls habe ich gesehen und einige Läden waren aber total leer und andere wahrscheinlich so die Innenläden waren komplett voll.
Also ich habe zumindest so Bars gesehen, wo es einfach voll war irgendwie eng.
Gehe ich keine Masken, also das hatte so ein bisschen was, als wäre jetzt nicht ein Lokdown angekündigt worden, sondern die atomare Zerstörung Berlins irgendwie so nächste Woche.
Alle müssen nochmal richtig drauf halten, aber,
Ich sag dann immer dazu, das ist so adäquische Evidenz, ne? Sagt natürlich jetzt überhaupt nichts aus. Jeder jemand mag woanders langgegangen sein und da waren alle ganz piesig. Aber es ist einfach, sagen wir mal so.
Man kann zumindest nicht davon ausgehen, dass wir jetzt so eine uniforme Reaktion der Gesellschaft erleben werden.
Gerade auch aus den äh vorhin schon benannten Gründen. Aber wir gehen ja eh gleich nochmal den Lokdown seiner äh in seinen Beschlüssen nochmal einzeln durch. Lassen sie's nochmal kurz bei den Zahlen bleiben.
Ja. Also
ja Berlin vielleicht noch Friedrichshain Kreuzberg bei der Institanz jetzt knapp hinter Neukölln
aber äh dafür steigt's eben wie gesagt jetzt schneller, deswegen äh in in Friedrichshain Kreuzberg, deswegen liegt es in meiner Risiko
vorne und Pankow, was von der Institanz her,
bisschen zurücklag, hat jetzt dafür die höchste Zunahme, also es ist jetzt dann irgendwie nach Pankow rein und jetzt ziehen die Zahlen in Pankow an gerade.
Warum auch immer.
Habe ich ja gerade berichtet. Es war ja sozusagen ein Bericht aus Panko.
Ja äh.
Läuft's.
Und ansonsten ja haben wir jetzt auch in den letzten äh Sendungen
immer so den Blick auch in die Nachbarländer gemacht, weil das ist der ist natürlich auch sehr aufschlussreich, weil die uns zum Teil jetzt voraus sind und äh ja,
man natürlich auch gerne wissen möchte, wie stehen wir denn im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern eigentlich da? Und ähm da kann man sagen.
Bislang,
standen wir sehr gut da im Vergleich zu allen Nachbarländern. Jetzt stehen wir immer noch.
Aber äh ja,
es geht halt auch bei uns hoch. Es sieht eher so aus, als wenn's bei uns auch ein bisschen mit Verspätung äh kommt.
Du hast uns sicherlich ein bisschen Einblick in die Situation in Tschechien.
Die jetzt sich gerade so mit Belgien um Platz eins in Europa äh boxen
Du hast ja gesagt, die haben Maßnahmen ergriffen, kannst du mal sagen, was die genau für Maßnahmen ergriffen haben, wann sie die ergriffen haben und äh wie das so rüberkommt bei dir.
Anfang, anfangs hast du sie ja noch gelobt, dass sie so mit Seuchen und so weiter sich ja so super auskennen und so. Davon scheint ja wenig übrig geblieben zu sein.
Ja, ja. Also ähm,
was in Tschechien passiert ist, ist, dass man nachdem man die erste Welle mit drastischen Maßnahmen wirklich mit am besten in den Griff gekriegt hat, so
in Europa und speziell im Osten,
ja war man halt so zuversichtlich, dass man halt das Ende von Corona ausgerufen hat. Im Prinzip, das heißt, man hat eigentlich.
Alle Beschränkungen aufgehoben. So.
Im Großen und Ganzen, so meint einfach so Korona ist nicht mehr. Äh wir machen jetzt wieder auf.
Und es war auch tatsächlich so, allerdings sind dann halt die Tschechen fahren halt besonders gerne auch so nach ins ehemalige Jugoslawien, speziell Kroatien
ist ein beliebter Urlaubsort äh so für Tschechen und ja da haben die dann natürlich äh dann kräftig aus dem Urlaub,
ja das Virus zurückgebracht
offiziell ja war Corona ja vorbei und deswegen ja hat man sich dann hat man's halt einfach laufen lassen so und hat's halt
ziemlich lange laufen lassen bis ja man's dann geschafft hat plötzlich innerhalb,
weniger Wochen von einem der ja besten
Länder äh in Europa zum möglicherweise sogar weltweiten ja,
Rekord Land zu werden, was die Institenz, was die Zahl der Neuerkrankungen pro Millionen Einwohner angeht.
Ja und was die Maßnahmen angeht, da ist eine ganz gute Quelle tatsächlich äh.
Vom Auswärtigen Amt, äh, was die sagen und.
Ja, Tschechien hatte am äh fünften Oktober einen dreißigtägigen Notstand ausgerufen.
Fünften Oktober.
Ja, fünften Oktober äh,
sagen, wurden die Änderungen äh äh gegen das ging es los, also wurde dieser Notstand ausgerufen.
Also fast vor vier Wochen.
Mhm. Genau. Und dann ähm ja wurde konkret,
sagen die Grenzen am zweiundzwanzigsten Oktober zugemacht.
Also Einreise nur noch aus triffigen Gründen nach Tschechien und keine touristischen Reisen mehr möglich,
und äh wer vor dem zweiundzwanzigsten Oktober eingereist ist.
Darf noch bleiben, aber äh ja äh keine neuen Urlauber mehr. Außerdem
sind äh ab wurden ab zweiundzwanzigsten Oktober alle Geschäfte und Dienstleistungs
Triebe geschlossen, außer zur Grundversorgung, also Lebensmittel, Apotheken, Drogerien und Reparaturen und Großhandelsgeschäfte, Übernachtungen auch nur noch für Dienstreisende
und ab dem achtundzwanzigsten Oktober müssen aber alle Geschäfte in der Zeit,
zwischen zwanzig Uhr und fünf Uhr und an Sonntagen schließen. Also dann, also es ist auch komplett dicht, weil in Tschechien gibt's halt nicht so ähm wie hier das Ladenschlussgesetz, sondern da haben Geschäfte halt, können halt aufhaben, wann sie wollen.
In der Woche oder zeitlich, das.
Dort unbeschränkt, deswegen gibt's dort jetzt die Beschränkung, die wir eigentlich sowieso fast haben, gut.
Nicht ganz, aber ja, also Geschäft, dann ebenfalls ab zweiundzwanzigsten Oktober eine Ausgangsbeschränkung außer Wege zur Arbeit, zur Familie, zum Arzt oder zum Einkaufen oder
Spaziergänge und Sport im Freien. Aber das wohl dann nochmal ab achtundzwanzigsten Oktober äh.
Verschärft ähm und äh seitdem besteht zwischen einundzwanzig Uhr abends und fünf Uhr morgens einen Ausgangsverbot äh außer äh für Wege zur Arbeit,
So ansonsten äh äh dürfen sich halt im.
Auch im Freien bis auf Ausnahmen wie Angehörige der gleichen äh äh Haushalte, Familienangehörige oder Arbeitskollegen maximal zwei Personen treffen,
also keine im Prinzip wie auch bei uns. Ähm.
Dazu gibt's dann auch noch irgendwie Abstandsvorschriften und Tragen eines
Mund und Nasenschutzes, also der muss an allen öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln, an Haltestellen im Freien, wo der Abstand nicht eingehalten werden kann
und in allen Innenräumen äh getragen werden, außer in Wohnungen oder Hotelzimmern. So,
Ja, das ist im Wesentlichen der,
in äh Tschechien, der sich manchmal ja äh.
Doch deutlich schärfer äh ist als das, was bei uns jetzt am Montag kommt. Also wesentlichen Unterschiede,
sehe ich, dass halt wesentlich mehr, also es hat alle Geschäfte und Dienstleistungsbetriebe geschlossen dann. Also der zahlt diejenigen Geschäfte, die noch offen bleiben dürfen, ist deutlich kleiner,
und dann natürlich der Hammer äh so das Ausgangsverbot nach einundzwanzig Uhr, also faktisch ein nächtliches,
Ausgangsverbot. So.
Ich vergleiche gerade mal die,
Zahlen, die ähm Tschechien zum Zeitpunkt des Beginns ihres Logdowns so hatte. Das äh ist jetzt mal auf eine Million, also pro pro äh Bevölkerungszahl quasi, also.
Permillion People sozusagen, also am fünften Oktober, als sie dann, wenn das da sozusagen der erste Tag war, äh waren das zwohundertachtunddreißig neue Fälle.
Also im Sieben-Tages-Everic jetzt, ne?
Äh Deutschland derzeit hundertvierundsechzig.
Und wir haben noch zwei Tage, die man vielleicht draufrechnen können. Ähm ja, gut. Wird nicht ganz da liegen, wo Tschechien quasi lag, aber.
Nah dran.
Auch nicht so weit weg, sagen wir es mal so, ne? Also das kann man jetzt so oder so rechnen. Ähm bisschen früher.
'ne Woche ungefähr.
Die Auswirkung wiederum sind krass, also jetzt gerade Stand heute,
äh die Todeszahlen gehen rasant nach oben, also die liegen da bei dreizehn Komma fünf pro Million.
Vergleicht Deutschland derzeit null Komma sechs sieben, also so richtig Fett. Ähm,
Belgien ist äh von unseren Nachbarländern
bei äh aktuelle Zahlen gibt's nicht nur von vorgestern, da lagen sie bei sieben Komma sieben, ich glaube, die sind wahrscheinlich auch jetzt so bei zehn oder so. Also Belgien traditionell auch schlimm, ne,
Aber Tschechien reißt es halt schon raus. Andererseits der Lokdown ist fast vier Wochen her.
Die Todeszahlen steigen jetzt erst recht, ne? Also man sieht.
Schleppende Kurve, eigentlich bestätigt sich genau das selbe Bild, was wir am Anfang auch hatten.
Sagen kann so na ja wussten wir ja schon, ne?
Keine Überraschung. Immerhin gut, guckt man,
jetzt äh auf äh sagen die die Gesamtzahlen, also die sagen
kumulierten Todeszahlen äh so gehen die rasant nach oben, aber dadurch, dass Tschechien halt in der ersten Welle eigentlich fast nichts hatte
ähm liegen sie jetzt immer noch unter EU-Durchschnitt. Äh so trotz aber.
Doppel so viel wie Deutschland.
Ja äh mittlerweile aber doppelt so viel wie Deutschland genau und äh lagen mal deutlich drunter noch vor.
Einem Monat,
so schnell kann's gehen und sie werden mit ziemlicher Sicherheit in den nächsten Wochen weit über den europäischen Durchschnitt erstmal auch hinausschießen
kann man in Kurven quasi ansehen, wenn man weiß, wie viel Verzögerung gerade bei den Todesfällen drin liegt.
Jetzt sind wir auf Tschechien äh als Beispiel gekommen weil du meintest,
Wir haben ja die Situation in anderen Ländern gesehen, ne? Und es ist ja jetzt nicht nur das, es halt Belgien eigentlich am laufenden Meter auch Frankreich ist, wieder extrem äh überlastet,
Süden ist es nicht ganz so schlimm, also die Schweiz hat sich erst vor ein paar Wochen beschleunigt,
durch ihr Jodel fest oder was auch immer, da der Auslöser war. Österreich ist so knapp hinter Deutschland, auch Dänemark, also nicht überall brennt's, aber es brennt halt in Frankreich und es brennt halt in Belgien, es brennt halt in Tschechien, so. Und ich meine,
jetzt kann man halt sagen, na ja okay, ist ja weit weg. Ähm gut Tschechien ist es so quasi wie Sachsen.
Ja, Frankreich könnte man auch sagen, es äh Saarland, ne? Also es ist einfach sehr nah an uns dran und von daher muss man das einfach genauso mit einrichten, aber man bleibt halt dann stur bei seinen eigenen Zahlen.
Vielleicht schauen wir mal, was ähm jetzt eigentlich beschlossen wurde.
Es hat sie sich ja schon abgezeichnet und am äh Mittwoch gab es äh eine längere Sitzung mit äh Merkel und den Landesfürsten sagt man auch immer so schön, ne?
Und haben dann halt äh sich dann endlich mal auf was einigen können.
Ich glaub es ist ganz ganz sinnvoll mal hier diese offizielle Beschluss Lage mal durchzugehen.
Ich lese das mal vor, äh jeden Punkt, dann können wir ja mal kurz sagen, was uns dazu einfällt, wenn uns was dazu einfällt.
Äh
Ab dem zweiten November treten deutschlandweit die empfolgenden dargelegten zusätzlichen Maßnahmen in Kraft. Die Maßnahmen werden bis Ende November befristet. Nach Ablauf von zwei Wochen werden die Bundeskanzlerin und die Regierungschefinnen und Regierungschefs
der Länder sich erneut beraten und die durch die Maßnahmen erreichten Ziele beurteilen und notwendige Anpassungen vornehmen. Kann man, glaube ich, schon mal vorwegnehmen.
Mhm.
Also schön, dass man äh sich in zwei Wochen nochmal treffen möchte, aber alles andere als äh weitere Verschärfungen oder mindestens eben die
ähm Beibehaltung der der Situation wird sich zeigen, ne?
Tschechien, wenn's läuft wie in Tschechien, dann wird in zwei Wochen verschärft und verlängert. So, so ist jedenfalls in Tschechien gelaufen.
Okay, gut. Schauen wir mal. Punkt zwei,
Wichtigste Maßnahme in der kommenden Zeit wird es seinen Abstand zu halten und Kontakte zu verringern, die Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden angehalten, die Kontakte zu anderen Menschen außerhalb der Angehörigen des eigenen Hausstands, auf ein absolut nötiges
Minimum zu reduzieren. Gut, das ist ein Appell, den hören wir jetzt schon seit Wochen, der ja gut den.
Gemeint, aber halt wenig äh konkret. Deswegen wird's jetzt in den nächsten Punkten etwas konkreter. Punkt drei.
Der Aufenthalt in der Öffentlichkeit ist daher ab sofort nur mit den Angehörigen des eigenen und eines weiteren Hausstandes, jedoch in jedem Fall im maximal mit zehn Personen gestattet. Dies gilt verbindlich und Verstöße gegen diese Kontaktbeschränkung.
Kontaktbeschrägung, Fett.
Werden entsprechend von den Ordnungsbehörden sanktioniert. Darüber hinaus gehende Gruppen feiern da Menschen auf öffentlichen Plätzen in Wohnungen sowie privaten Einrichtungen sind angesichts der ernsten Lage in unserem Land inakzeptabel. Bund und Länder wirken bei den verstärkten Kontrollen zusammen.
Gut, da wird kräftig mit dem Finger gewedelt. Äh.
Geht ja gar nicht, ne? Also hier ist halt explizit von Kontaktbeschränkungen äh die Rede, ne? Man will, glaube ich, hier.
Zu starke Wortwahl auch irgendwie vermeiden.
Punkt vier, Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden aufgefordert, generell auf nicht notwendige private Reisen und Besucher auch von Verwandten zu verzichten, das gilt auch im Inland
und für überregionale tagestouristische Ausflüge, Übernachtungsangebote im Inland werden nur noch für notwendige und ausdrücklich nicht touristische Zwecke zur Verfügung gestellt,
Ja, da freuen sich natürlich die äh Hotels kräftig drüber. Das ist natürlich auch so ein Grund, warum,
vielleicht bis zum November gewartet hat, es gibt nur noch ja ein zwei Bundesländer die Herbstferien haben, also Bayern hat jetzt noch eine Woche Ferien, die trifft's insof,
am härtesten, weil das bedeutet im Prinzip Urlaubsende und eigentlich sogar Urlaubszerstörung, weil die haben nur die eine Woche.
Äh Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hatte äh sogar auch nur ein paar Tage genau am zweiten und dritten, also auch dort äh.
Ist es sozusagen abgesagt.
Berlin hat gerade richtig hat's gerade richtig abgepasst sozusagen.
Ja gut, der ist ja seit letzter Woche schon vorbei, ne? Also Sachsen enden jetzt gerade die äh Ferien und in Thüringen auch. Und Baden-Württemberg auch. Also.
Gut das,
Wird nicht der einzige Faktor gewesen sein, aber das kann man ja vielleicht hier nochmal mit annehmen, aber so oder so äh ist natürlich blöd und das ist halt natürlich vor allem blöd für die Hotels, die äh können einem eh leid tun. Ich war ja jetzt äh die Woche auch nochmal unterwegs.
In Hotels und kann halt sagen, naja okay äh.
Das eh schon ziemlich traurige Veranstaltung, ne? Weil wie's da so in Friedrichsräumen abläuft und.
Ja, also wo ich ich war ja auch äh in der Zeit so vor.
Ein paar Wochen äh in München hatte ich ja erzählt, das war so äh also beruflich und,
ich muss sagen, ich habe mich jetzt nicht besonders unsicher gefühlt im Hotel, muss ich sagen. Alle waren mit Maske unterwegs und auch beim Frühstück äh und so äh,
unsere,
Gruppe in einem eigenen Raum, also getrennt von anderen und so und kein Buffet und alles wurde gebracht und ja,
Also so ich hatte jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass jetzt da von den von den
Hotels an sich eine große Gefahr angeht, aber das war auch beruflich und wahrscheinlich ich meine
deine Reise könnte man wäre eigentlich auch ganz klar beruflich, insofern könnte es jetzt.
Wäre wäre nicht nur wahr.
Ähm klar, mir wurde nicht gut, also jetzt jetzt würde natürlich von mir wahrscheinlich äh würde gerade mal wie das beim letzten Mal war. Da bin ich ja quasi auch.
Genau in der Woche unterwegs gewesen und da wurde dann schon mal nachgefragt äh.
Wobei sie sich, glaube ich, meistens mit äh der Aussage, es sei geschäftlich äh zufriedengeben. Im Zweifelsfall muss man's halt noch um die jetzt auch noch nachweisen.
Aber ich sehe das ganz genau so, also wenn ich jetzt ich meine, ich habe natürlich jetzt auch schon eine Risikoabwägung für mich
gemacht, ne? Zum einen jetzt nochmal ein paar Interviews äh waren auch sozusagen Face to Face Interviews. Muss ich natürlich auch entsprechende Maßnahmen ergreifen, habe ich auch getan, mich nochmal getestet, bevor ich losgefahren bin
mit dem Auto unterwegs und hab dann
ähm mit meiner Technik natürlich auch bei den bei den äh Interview entsprechend Abstand äh gehalten und war da halt irgendwie.
Ganz klar meinen Gesprächspartner gegenüber habe ich halt genau gesagt, was Phase ist. Das war dann soweit alles in Ordnung. Ich denke, dass äh.
Doch klappen, aber jetzt zurück hier zu den Lokdown Regeln äh ist schade für die Hotels. Ich kann's sehr nachvollziehen, weil man will natürlich diese Bewegung rauskriegen,
Und das kann man einfach nur, indem man halt Urlaub jetzt einfach unterbindet. Wenn man den Geschäftsreisen halt noch ermöglicht, okay, schön, gut, das äh hilft der Wirtschaft so ein bisschen am Laufen zu bleiben. Für die Hotels ist es natürlich dünner.
So, jetzt wird's spannend. Punkt fünf. Institutionen und Einrichtungen, die der Freizeitgestaltung zuzuordnen sind, werden geschlossen. Dazu gehören A, Theater, Opern, Konzerthäuser und ähnliche Einrichtungen
bemessen, Kinos, Freizeitparks und Anbieter von Freizeitaktivitäten drin und draußenhallen, Spielbanken, Bettannahmestellen und ähnliche Einrichtungen.
C Prostitutionsstätten, Bordelle und ähnliche Einrichtungen.
Die der Freizeit und Amateursportbetrieb mit Ausnahme des Individualsports allein zu zweit oder mit dem eigenen Hausstand auf und in allen öffentlichen und privaten Sportanlagen. Also kein Squash mehr, kein.
Nichts mehr einfach dicht.
Zweit. Äh geht noch. Das wäre individuell. Nee, ist das ist Squash jetzt Individualsport zu zweit. Hm.
Na ja, also wenn die Anbieter von Freizeitaktivitäten drin und draußen zu schließen haben, das ist definitiv eine Freizeitaktivität, äh Individualsport ist halt du darfst draußen joggen.
Vermutlich ist das so gemach.
Ja, also das denke ich schon, ne?
Ja, also kein Tennis mehr. Mhm.
Wobei hier ist auch in allen öffentlichen und privaten Sportanlagen. Ja, es ist wahrscheinlich eher draußen. Also ich vermute mal, das wird eher dicht sein. Dann äh E Schwimmen und Spaß, Bäder, Saunen und Thermen, Fitnessstudios und ähnliche Einrichtungen.
So, also Freizeitgestaltung findet nicht statt.
Quasi die Aussage von Punkt fünf und ich denke, das ist auch alles richtig und muss auch so sein. So, das ist schön finde ich die Feststellung, dass Prostitutionsstätten und Bordelle Teil der Freizeitgestaltung sind.
Sechstens, äh auch wenig überraschend Veranstaltungen, die der Unterhaltung dienen werden untersagt. Profisportveranstaltungen können nur ohne Zuschauer stattfinden.
Veranstaltungen, die der Unterhaltung dienen werden untersagt. Mhm. Das heißt, wenn eine Veranstaltung nicht unterhaltsam ist.
Da kenne ich ja so einige Comedians aus dem deutschen Fernsehen, die könnten jetzt einfach weitermachen. Also was heißt denn das? Veranstaltungen, die der Unterhaltung dienen.
Also was heißt denn das vor allem? Also was was schließt denn das sozusagen aus oder was oder nicht mit ein? Veranstaltung so.
Na ja, da sind sozus.
Oben waren's, das ist sozusagen das Pendant zu Institutionen und Einrichtungen, aber es gibt dann halt noch Veranstaltungen, die,
halt, ja, vielleicht ohne institutionellen Rahmen stattfinden oder in keiner besonderen Einrichtung, die der Freizeitgestaltung zuzuordnen, ist also was weiß ich
auch deine Technoparty im Lokschuppen oder so, ja oder in der in der äh in der Scheune.
Also für mich liest sich das so wie alles, was wirtschaftliche Wirtschaftsveranstaltungen sind, Meetings sind davon nicht unmittelbar getroffen.
Also es klingt so, als wenn ja man jetzt Vorträge oder Lehrveranstaltungen oder ähm ja solche Dinge äh.
Workshops, ja.
Weiterbildung kann stattfinden. Okay, bleibt ein bisschen unklar.
Siebtens, Gastronomiebetriebe sowie Bars, Clubs, Diskotheken, Kneipen und ähnliche Einrichtungen werden geschlossen. Davon ausgenommen ist die Lieferung und Abholung mitnahmefähiger Speisen für den Verzehr zu Hause, sowie der Betrieb von Kantinen.
Auch hier wieder äh Kantine, also Betriebe sollen irgendwie am Laufen gehalten werden, also es ist fließt einfach links und rechts aus dieser Verordnung, äh Business soll weiterlaufen können,
in irgendeiner Form,
mit Hygieneauflagen und so weiter, aber ist halt nicht man wird nicht explizit gezwungen, sondern es geht halt wirklich hier um diesen privaten Freizeitanteil und.
Die Auflistung mit Barsclubs, Diskotheken und Kneipen, da haben wir dann sozusagen auch, glaube ich, die Top-Verlierer dieser dieses Jahres auch schön aneinander gereiht, nicht dass die anderen nicht auch in irgendeiner Form betroffen sind,
auch vorhin hier so Theater et cetera, ist natürlich auch Messen sowieso. Ja, das ist die sind alle in irgendeiner Form betroffen, aber ich glaube nichts ist so sehr betroffen
eben Barskneipen, Clubs, Diskotheken das ganze Jugendliche leben, sage ich mal, nicht nur Jugendliche, aber vor allem eben das Jugendliche leben
Das äh findet einfach derzeit nicht statt und das wird noch ziemlich schwierig werden, ähm das alles aufzufangen.
Ja, Restaurants können halt wieder auf äh Lieferungen schalten und dann kann man nur hoffen, dass die sich alle entsprechend angepasst haben und äh zusehen, dass sie jetzt hier zumindest ähm.
An Minimum, an an Wirtschaftsbetrieb aufrechterhalten äh können. Können so einige, die haben.
Glaube ich, ganz gut gelebt in der Zwischenzeit und ihr suchen noch davon profitiert, weil das halt eh so ihr.
Zentrales Business ist, aber das gilt natürlich für die wenigsten äh der Restaurants.
Punkt acht, Dienstleistungsbetriebe im Bereich der Körperpflege, sowie äh wie Kosmetikstudios.
Massagepraxen, Tattoo, Studios und ähnliche Betrieben werden geschlossen, weil in diesem Bereich eine körperliche Nähe un
Dingbar ist medizinisch notwendige Behandlung, zum Beispiel Physio, Erngo und Logo, Therapien, sowie Podologie, Fußpflege bleiben weiter möglich. Friseursalons bleiben unter den bestehenden Auflagen zur Hygiene geöffnet.
Äh eine Lexfriseursalon.
Ja, eine Lex, wir äh lassen mal alles, wo die Leute sich jetzt besonders.
Sagen wir mal so, also Friseur ist ja so ein Ding.
Ich erinnere mich dann immer an diese diese äh Demo von diesen äh Trump, Corona-Feinden.
So die irgendwie protestieren gegangen sind. Also auf der einen Seite hat's so diese protestierende, die so, ja, erschießt uns nicht.
Black Lifes Messer irgendwie wir wir wollen überleben und bitte nicht jeden Tag einen von uns erschießen und auf der anderen Seite hast du so die weißen Privilegierten, die dann halt mit so Forderungen wie daher kamen,
auch echt sagen muss, äh, nichts zeigt schöner, äh, wer hier welche Probleme hat.
Mhm.
Trotzdem machte sich irgendwie an den Haaren, macht sich dann so einiges fest, weil quasi diese fortschreitende Haar äh Länge,
permanent sozusagen täglich und kontinuierlich immer wieder klar gemacht hat so was gerade alles nicht passiert.
Ne? Und äh ich glaube auch das hier ist so ein Ding. Man hat auf der einen Seite festgestellt, okay, Infektionen im Friseursalon sind jetzt nicht so das große Ding.
Ganz im Gegenteil gab ja auch Berichte, wo man wusste, hier äh Friseurin war infiziert und hatte irgendwie dreißig Kunden keiner infiziert und so weiter, aber was weiß ich. Ich habe da nicht so den direkten Einblick. Auf jeden Fall halte ich das auch noch für zumutbar,
ist aber auch.
Ja aber das Problem ist natürlich erstens, die Leute müssen natürlich irgendwie hinkommen und wieder zurückkommen so.
Zum Friseur und es kommt zu Kontakten einfach ja zusätzlichen so und,
wenn du jetzt anfängst, ja,
mit aber Friseursalons, da ist nicht viel passiert, dann äh wird die Liste dann auf einmal plötzlich echt lang, da können dann viele Restaurants können dann auch sagen, okay, hier bei uns
ist nichts passiert, ja? Und äh so gut ist halt jetzt so.
Ist richtig oder so. Ich sag nur I know what you talking about. Ja also so wie bisher schon überall dieses Wirtschaft muss laufen,
irgendeiner Form mit drinsteckt ist halt hier eben auch dieses wir wollen so die totalen Aufreger, wo die Leute einfach schnell on the sind
irgendwie rausnehmen. Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt alle irgendwie permanent nur noch beim Friseur rumhängen, aber es gibt zumindest.
Nicht noch diesen Aufreger noch mit dazu und dann ist das ein gewisser Hinsicht so ein praktikables politisches Opfer. Da wollen wir uns ja eh gleich nochmal drüber unterhalten, wie das Ganze politisch äh zu bewerten ist,
Punkt neun, der Groß- und Einzelhandel bleibt unter Auflagen zur Hygiene zur Steuerung des Zutritts und zur Vermeidung von Warteschlangen insgesamt geöffnet. Dabei ist sicherzustellen, dass sich in den Geschäften nicht mehr als ein Grunde pro.
Zehn Quadratmeter Verkaufsfläche auffällt. Das ist im Prinzip der Statusquo, den wir schon in äh in der ersten äh Phase auch hatten. Klar, äh Supermärkte müssen laufen, wenn die,
nicht da ist, gibt's einen Aufstand und das gilt natürlich auch für den Großhandel. Äh wir werden aber dann sozusagen wieder diese starken Befüllungsregime haben.
So, jetzt wird's spannend, zehn Schulen und Kindergärten bleiben offen. Die Länder entscheiden über die erforderlichen Schutzmaßnahmen.
Ja
Also ich habe ja zwei zwei Kinder in der Schule und kann da nur äh schwer atmen. Ähm.
Auch hier, ich verstehe vollständig die politische Abwägung, die einfach.
Offensichtlich ist, wenn die Schulen und die Kindergärten,
nicht geöffnet sind, ist das Wirtschaftsleben komplett on the. Das haben wir ja gesehen. Gerade für äh alleinerziehende, aber eigentlich auch für alle Eltern, insbesondere umso jünger die Kinder sind.
Umso schwieriger ist das Ganze.
Bei Kindergärten kann man sagen, gut, ich weiß ja jetzt nicht, wieso die Auswertung äh waren, was da jetzt tatsächlich alles vorgefallen ist. Kindergärten sind halt im Idealfall relativ kleine Gruppen, die halt auch sehr.
Unter sich bleiben, ne? Also.
Kalkulierbares Risiko in gewisser Hinsicht. Schulen je nach hygienischen Maßnahmen und Trennung der Klassen und Verhalten auf dem Pausenhof.
Vielleicht auch.
Trotz alledem, das haben wir ja schon in den Zahlen gesehen. Es gibt halt schon eine Korrelation mit Schulöffnung und ähm und und im Verlauf der Zahlen. Ich sage nicht, das ist der Grund dafür. Ich sage nur.
Es gibt eine Koolation, ne, die man irgendwie interpretieren muss.
Also am Ende muss man das so sehen, wenn man wieder ähm.
Blick auf diese Reproduktionszahl wirft, die ja zwar problematisch ist, aber trotzdem irgendwie einen Anhaltspunkt äh.
Einer ganzen guten,
bietet so wie gut man denn jetzt grade bekämpft oder nicht bekämpft oder wie erfolgreich der Virus eigentlich gerade ist und,
ist ja bekannt, der muss eigentlich unter eins sein, damit die Zahlen runtergehen, sobald der über eins ist, gehen die Zahlen hoch. So und ähm,
jede einzelne Maßnahme ähm.
Fügt äh ja zieht ein bisschen was von diesem Faktor,
ja, das heißt, es ist eine Summe aus ganz, ganz vielen einzelnen Maßnahmen, die irgendwie was bringen
Und wir haben jetzt zusätzlich noch das Problem, dadurch, dass jetzt die Zahlen so hochgeschossen sind, dass jetzt die Gesundheitsämter mit dem Trekking und Tracing nicht mehr äh
hinterher kommen. Ich schätze, dass die so null Komma eins bis null Komma zwei irgendwie eingedämmt haben die ganze Zeit
ja. Die sind aber jetzt dieser Dam ist quasi gebrochen,
Das heißt, äh, wir müssen irgendwie anderweitig jetzt diese null Komma eins null Komma zwei kompensieren und ja,
Und dann ist es natürlich so, wenn wir es jetzt unter eins kriegen, ist dann die Frage, wie weit kriegen wir's denn unter eins? Wenn wir jetzt bei null Komma neun neun bleiben.
So dann aber bei einer Zahl von fünfzigtausend Neuinfektionen am Tag, dann ist das auch nicht nachhaltig. Das heißt, wir müssen halt deutlich,
unter eins runter kommen
damit die Zahlen äh wieder in eine Größenordnung kommen, wo man dann ja mit Trekking und Nachverfolgen und gezielten Isolationen wieder diese weiß ich nicht null Komma eins null Komma zwei
Dämpfung der Ausbreitung äh des des äh Virus bekommt. So und dann.
Will man natürlich auch noch einen Sicherheitsabstand haben, weil natürlich wenn man dann jetzt der Logdown ausläuft,
dann äh geht natürlich zwangsläufig R äh wieder nach oben, so um einen bestimmten äh
wert, ja? Das heißt, äh, wenn man Lock hat, dann will man
zum einen erstlockern, wenn die Zahlen tief genug sind, aber auch wenn man einen ordentlichen, ja, Abstand beim R, was weiß ich, null Komma sieben oder null Komma acht.
Sollte man
alt schon haben, weil wenn du bei null Komma neun fünf lockerst, wie wir das beim letzten Mal gemacht haben, dann bist du ruckzuck wieder über eins und die Zahlen gehen schon wieder nach oben und dann äh spielen wir das Spiel nochmal
wieder im Februar oder März, ja, haben wir dann wieder die nächsten äh Lokdown. So,
außerdem besteht natürlich noch das Szenario, sagt das das äh ja.
Gar nicht in Griff kriegen, weil jetzt durch die kalte Jahreszeit und so irgendwie noch äh
und offene Schulen und die ganzen anderen Lücken und berufliche Kontakte und öffentliche Verkehrsmittel und so weiter. Ja äh plus Winter
da wissen wir auch, dass das Virus im Winter viel länger überleben kann, auch vor allen Dingen auf Oberflächen, das heißt es kann sein, dass jetzt plötzlich,
neue Infektionswege kriegen, die wegen der Temperatur jetzt nicht so akut waren, aber das plötzlich jetzt das Virus tagelang auf irgendwelchen Oberflächen drum
lungert und äh ja kann äh alles alles passieren und dann äh kann's eben sein, dass wir plötzlich feststellen, ja wir kriegen,
die zahlen nicht wirklich runter, weil der Winter gegen uns weiter arbeitet, ja? Wer jetzt keine Horrorszenarien an die Wand äh malen, aber,
Alle gehen, alle gehen, nee, alle gehen davon aus, dass das funktioniert mit den Eindämmen, weil wir haben das ja schließlich schon einmal gemacht.
Geht auch und ich glaube eigentlich auch daran, dass das dass das funktionieren wird, aber ich habe da so gewisse Re
Zweifel, ja? Weil es ist jetzt auch der erste Winter, in den wir so reinlaufen mit,
eben solchen hohen Infektionszahlen und da
kann niemand so genau vorhersagen, was da äh passieren wird und wie die Dynamik sich äh entwickeln wird. Aber mein Gefühl ist, sagt, wir werden nochmal nachlegen,
mit mit Maßnahmen weil der Winter gegen uns arbeitet, weil die Gesundheitsämter nicht mitkommen und äh ja weil wir äh halt noch trotz,
dieses Logdowns immer noch eine Menge Kontakte haben werden und ihr habt irgendwo gelesen, als hätte jemand berechnet, dass wir die Zahl der Kontakte auf fünfundzwanzig Prozent reduzieren müssen,
Ja, von dem, was jetzt äh ja von aktuell oder vor zwei Wochen oder wie auch auch immer, ja und.
Ob das ausreicht, äh also ob die Maßnahmen ausreichen, um äh so viel zu reduzieren, werden sie. Mein es wird auf jeden Fall was bringen, aber die große Frage, die wo ich.
Unsicherheiten habe es, äh, wird es ausreichen und ähm wie lange wird der ganze Spaß dauern.
Interessant ist halt vor allem in dieser Liste eben, was alles nicht drin steht, ne? Also äh Wirtschaft haben wir ja schon rausgearbeitet, was auch ähm irgendwie gar nicht erwähnt wird, sind Kirchen, so religiöse.
Das ist genau das war die Frage, genau, was fehlt auffällig äh in dieser ganzen Aufzählung und das ist tatsächlich Kirchen oder ja religiöse Städten oder äh wie auch,
immer die fallen wahrscheinlich nicht in den Bereich der Freizeitgestaltung.
Also zumindest hätte man sie dann als Beispiel doch vielleicht schon mal aufführen sollen so, also.
Mhm. Aber ich habe.
Opern, Konzerthäuser und ähnliche Einrichtungen. Nee, messen, Kinos, Freizeitparks, auch nicht so richtig. Bordelle auch weniger so, ja.
Ja, aber ich habe irgendwo in einem anderen Artikel äh gelesen äh da stand das explizit drin. Das wohl jemand nachgefragt hat und Kirchen können aufbleiben.
Ja, da ist ja, wo ja auch überhaupt nichts passiert ist, ne? Also.
Genau. Mhm.
Also, das ist, das ist, sagen wir mal, jetzt echt das große Ding und äh unter dem Gesichtspunkt würde ich mir würde ich mich.
Deiner Einschätzung anschließen, dass das unter Umständen auch eins der Opfer dann sein könnte in zwei Wochen.
Also im Moment sehen für mich die Maßnahmen äh einfach aus wie Tool Little Tolate. Ja.
Das Ganze vor vier Wochen wäre wahrscheinlich eine ganz andere Geschichte gewesen, ne.
Das Ganze vor vier Wochen in dem Ausmaß dann äh ja hätten wir es äh vielleicht dabei belasten können
so aber ich hab ja einfach aus den Beispielen aus dem Ausland und immerhin in Tschechien hat auch die Schulen geschlossen, ja? Muss man äh dazu sagen
und musste dann nochmal nachlegen. Äh so also ähm ja.
Guckt, also ja die sind trotzdem halt dann bis jetzt was über zwölfhundert pro Million äh nach oben gegangen. Wenn du dann noch damit dann noch äh.
Ja auch eine die Dunkelziffer mit einberechnest, aber selbst wenn du die nicht mit einberechnest, so dann hat sich da in der letzten Woche, seit sie über tausend sind. Ähm hat sich da jeden Tag.
Promille der Bevölkerung infiziert oder jeder Tausendste, ja jeder Tausendste in der Bevölkerung hat sich täglich angest.
Und.
Und wahrscheinlich jeder fünfhundertste in der Realität oder jeder dreihundertste ungefähr und das ist natürlich ja äh gewaltig.
Das ist gewaltig, vor allem wenn man die Dunkelziffer noch mit einrechnet, äh.
Da da braucht's jetzt nicht mehr so viel für Fantasie und man ist schnell bei, na ja okay, also wenn jetzt hier auf dem Papier jeder Tausendste und man hat noch eine Dunkelziffer von irgendwie drei bis fünf
dann heißt das ja dann so viel, dass so äh pro bis jetzt pro Woche, ne? Oder.
Ne das war pro Tag.
Aha pro Tag. So, das heißt, dann dauert's auch nicht mehr so lange und dann haben wir dann doch noch irgendwie unsere Herden Immunität oder anders ausgesucht, dann hat's trotzdem irgendwie jeden erreicht.
Das äh werden dann noch ja irgendwie wenn das ein halbes Jahr so weitergrassieren äh würde. Aber das wäre halt dann auch der absolute Worst Case so,
und äh dazu denke ich wird's nicht kommen, zumal man in Tschechien ja jetzt sehen kann, dass es äh ja,
zumindest zum Stillstand gekommen ist, die tägliche Infektionsrate ist immer noch hoch, aber sie steigt zumindest nicht mehr.
Ja gut, aber zu welchem Preis, weil äh da kommt ja auch noch so anderes zum Stillstand, das ist ja nicht nur die Infektionsrate, die zum Stillstand kommt, sondern das ist dann halt eigentlich auch die Gesellschaft, die zum Stillstand kommt und das äh ja hat natürlich dann wiederum ganz viele andere Nebeneffekte,
läuft's? Ja, vielleicht mal lass uns doch nochmal ein bisschen,
mit so einer politischen Brille äh draufwerfen. Jetzt haben wir sozusagen diese ja was eigentlich geschehen müsste, Brille ist da, ne? Aber was wir jetzt natürlich auch sehen, ist.
So, wenn du Bundeskanzlerin wärst, Pavel, ne.
Ja
Und nicht einfach nur so aus deinem äh Wohnzimmer heraus, während dir in Ruhe die nächste Zigarette drehst, irgendwie dir so denkst, so, oh ja, die Zahlen habe ich mir jetzt mal ein paar Tage angeguckt und ich denke das und das,
da hast du es natürlich irgendwie mit einem.
Ja womit hat man's denn zu tun? Du hast ja nun auch fünf Jahre äh aktiv in der Politik äh verbracht, warst natürlich jetzt nicht äh Kanzlerin oder äh Bürgermeisterin, aber du hast es ja ein bisschen mitbekommen.
Genau, dann äh ja gescheiterte Oppositionspolitiker äh sagen,
Nein, aber das äh ja, das waren natürlich äh äh schon ähm krasse Einblicke jetzt nicht,
ganz so viel ins Regierungsgeschehen, aber ein bisschen halt auch und äh ja das Ding war da nicht mein ein Witz
der der das vielleicht ganz gut beschreibt, äh den ich irgendwie von dem Grünen gehört habe, war
Ja, warum tun sich eigentlich nicht alle vernünftigen Politiker aller Parteien zusammen und stellen mal eine vernünftige Regierung, weil sie in der Minderheit sind
So, das äh ja äh wie gesagt.
Ähm.
Und äh das beschreibt äh äh das Ganze vielleicht ganz gut. Also ich meine, du hast es damit ech.
Eigentlich ganz speziellen Gestalten zu tun, durch durchweg, ja, das ist sind in seltensten Fällen hast du dann normale Leute
die in die Politik gehen, weil eigentlich ja um in die Politik zu gehen. Gut, entweder ja ist irgendwie familiär vorbelastet so, das kommt auch öfter vor oder.
Im guten wie im Schlechten, ne.
Ja ja ähm.
Nee, oder? Äh man hat irgendeine Unzufriedenheit äh in sich. Da muss das schon irgendwie einen Wunsch und einen Wille dahinter äh stehen äh oder vielleicht ein besonderes Talent oder so, aber äh also es
Erstmal muss man sagen, dass intellektuelle Niveau ist im Allgemeinen nicht sehr hoch,
in einem Parlament, ja. Äh wobei äh,
ist da auch halt das den üblichen Gesetzen äh Verteilungsgesetzen äh äh verfolgt und es gibt da auch äh sehr clevere Leute und auch sehr tolle Leute und auch bewundernswerte,
Leute ja für unterschiedliches bewundern kann und,
auf Bundesebene sagen liegt die Latte schon noch ein bisschen höher, wobei ich auch eine Reihe von Bundestagsabgeordneten aus verschiedensten Fraktionen kenne. Also insofern kann ich das halt auch ein bisschen.
Einschätzen und was ich verstanden habe war, dass.
Regierung oder Staat eigentlich fast immer zu spät kommt. Das ist eigentlich immer erst reagiert wird, wenn,
reagiert werden muss
so wenn es halt einen deutlichen Missstand gibt und wenn es irgendwie ja genügend Initiative gibt, wo auch immer sie herkommen, um äh das Ganze zu beseitigen.
Es ist sozusagen das das eine äh Ding, das heißt äh ja dann ist natürlich das gesamte System maximal auf Stabilit,
ausgerichtet
und schon in gewisser Weise auf einen gewissen Konsens, man möchte es schon möglichst vielen Leuten recht machen, weil das sind ja Wähler und je mehr Leute irgendwie glücklich sind. Das heißt, es ist
schon sagen, grundsätzlich die Absicht oder der Wunsch da,
möglichst viele Gruppen äh zu hören und dann zu einer Lösung zu kommen, die jetzt auch für bestimmte Gruppen und billige Härten vermeidet oder so, dass es das, was dann
So im Ausschussbetrieb stattfindet äh und so. Jetzt muss man aber auch noch sagen,
Das was jetzt bei Corona gelaufen ist, praktisch ohne direkte Beteiligung der Parlamente
gelaufen ist. Das ist alles eher regierungshandeln gewesen und äh
Parlament oder die Parlamente fangen jetzt erst so langsam an zu sagen, hey Moment mal, also wir wollen da jetzt aber bisschen mehr einbezogen da nächsten Montag gibt's eine Sondersitzung des Abgeordnetenhauses
äh dazu zu den Maßnahmen beispielsweise in Berlin, keine Ahnung, ob ich mir die mal ausnahmsweise anhören werde, habe ich halt lange nicht gemacht. Ich meine, wenn man da.
Fünf Jahre lang dann an manchen Tagen acht bis zehn Stunden lang in dem Plenarsaal verbringt, dann ja.
Dann reicht's auch erstmal, dann hat man jetzt nicht so den den Bedarf äh jetzt äh sich das da auch noch weiter an äh zu gucken. Ja ähm,
So, also wie gesagt, es ist eigentlich typisch, dass dass das alles langsam, dass Politik
langsam funktionieren. Es ist sagen Absicht, das ist Design Prinzip, weil man will halt keine zu schnellen, krassen Veränderungen äh so normalerweise. Aber das ist natürlich so.
In der Pandimie ist das natürlich äh grundsätzlich problematisch, wenn man nicht
schnell ist und wenn man nicht rechtzeitig handelt und wenn man es versucht irgendwie dann doch möglichst vielen Leuten recht zu machen und Schmerzen zu vermeiden. Das ist ja alles sagen, ja, nachvollziehbar und ist ganz normales politisches Handeln und äh ist halt normal in einer Demokratie
So, dann kommt aber auch noch dazu, dass die meisten Parlamentarier echt schlecht in Mathe sind,
So und auch schlecht in Physik und äh schlecht in Logik äh und so. Ja. Also das ist äh äh bis Weilen. Also ich habe da so ein paar Dinge.
Erlebt so,
bei ja speziell jetzt beim Entwurf von Gesetzen, so wo du denkst, das geht auf keine Kuhhau.
Ja, es würde vielleicht jetzt zu weit führen, aber so ja einfach so Logikfehler, äh auf die ich dann.
Anschließend in der Pause nochmal die.
Gierungskoalition oder ein äh die SPD damals hingewiesen habe, die es daraufhin verstanden hat, dass sozusagen die Änderung, die sie da einbringen wollten, äh komplett ihren Schutz
aushebelt und ja
haben dann panisch noch 'ne zweite Änderung daraufhin darein verhandelt die noch weniger logischen Sinn machte die eigentlich dieses ganze Gesetz also wenn du das dann gelesen hast das
hä?
Äh zu was wollen die hier äh zur.
Also äh so das war so so ein äh Ding äh was ich, was ich erlebt habe,
plus dann Geheimbeteiligungsausschuss oder so äh ja.
Ist niemandem aufgefallen, wenn da irgendwie mal hundertzwanzig Millionen in irgendeiner Bilanz fehlten oder so, war jetzt nun,
Fehler in dem Dokument, was uns vorgelegt worden ist, aber eben, ja, also kannst jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass dass da jetzt so mit besonderer
Sorgfalt oder Detailkenntnis äh vorgegangen wir.
Ist noch keiner wegen seiner Mathekenntnisse ins Parlament gekommen, sagst du.
Ja, das das Gefühl hatte, wie gesagt, es gibt überall Ausnahmen so, muss ich sagen, waren jetzt alles Idioten und so ich muss muss sagen.
Was Politik halt aber auch erfordert und was der Grund war, warum ich auch nicht weiter,
machen wollte, ist äh man muss halt ganz viele Spiele tatsächlich mitspielen. Man muss sich halt bei allen möglichen Gruppen,
auch.
Richtig gesagt, Anbietern, was natürlich extrovertierten Menschen deutlich einfacher äh fällt,
und ja, da habe ich halt einfach äh ähm solche Schmeichlerprofis äh äh.
Gesehen in bei Kollegen so, wo ich dachte, nee äh also,
das kann ich einfach nicht. Ja? Ich kann mich da nicht äh ich weiß nicht. So auf diese Art und Weise an, wie dann bei wildfremden Menschen. So.
Gegen der Natur. Ja, das kann ich, kann ich gut nachvollziehen, aber man sieht ja auch, dass genau solche Vögel ja, was weiß ich hier so, Philipp Amtor und so weiter, dann äh auf einmal eine Rolle einnehmen, wo man sich fragt, womit er das eigentlich verdient hat.
Ja. Mehr man zahlt halt schon einen einen hohen Preis und das ist der Wettbewerb ist auch hoch. Die Zahl der Jobs in der Politik ist doch sehr begrenzt. Das ist doch eine sehr spezialisierte Geschichte. Es gibt,
keinen richtigen Ausbildungsberuf oder so, sondern muss da eigentlich eher früh in eine Partei rein und dann auch durchaus lange bleiben, außer
es kommen jetzt irgendwelche neuen Parteien plötzlich hoch, dann so wie das bei mir passiert
ist und man dann plötzlich in den Parlament reinschwappt und erstmal überhaupt keine Ahnung hat von dem was denn da vor sich geht und dass man das auch nirgendwo nachlesen kann, ja? So das erste Mal in meinem Leben, wo ich nicht in die Bibliothek gehen konnte
und äh einfach nachlesen konnte, wie das alles funktioniert. Es ist halt ganz, ganz viel. So geübte Praxis, was da abläuf.
Fällst durch alle Formulare als Abgeordneter, wenn du irgendwo eine Versicherung abschließen willst oder so. Die Rubrik Abgeordneter gibt's nirgendwo.
Den rechtlichen Status. Also.
Wirklich.
Ja, gibt's nicht. So, meistens hat man dann irgendwie zu Beschäftigter im öffentlichen Dienst oder so gegriffen, aber das ist es halt nicht. Äh so.
Ja, es es wirst du nicht als.
Geordneter ist einfach kein Beruf.
Ja, es ist irgendwie auch kein ja.
Ja, gut, aber wie erklärt denn das jetzt sozusagen unsere Gemengelage? Also es quält natürlich schon links und rechts ein wenig heraus, was du sagst so, dass das einfach ein großer Kompromiss ist, ne.
Ich mein was es gab gestern in der BZ glaube ich so die Schlagzeile wie ja
wie Möller sagt, wie betrübt sie denn alle im Senat waren, dass sie jetzt die Maßnahmen für Berlin auch alle umsetzen müssen und was für ein schwerer Tag das war und wie
ungern man denn sowas beschließt und alle lange Gesichter und so und ja eigentlich wollen wir das nicht, aber
ist, wir haben leider keine andere Wahl, es ist alternativlos, aber wir möchten euch das wirklich nicht eigentlich nicht zumuten, aber.
Ja, wir haben jetzt so lange gewartet, hat er jetzt nicht gesagt.
Bis es eigentlich schon fast nichts mehr bring.
Bis es bis es zu spät war, äh bis es fast zu spät war,
Und jetzt ist es eigentlich jetzt geht's halt nicht mehr anders. So jetzt. Äh ja
Also wer nach dem Motto, wir haben das jetzt so nah rangefahren an die Katastrophe äh wie wir uns das getraut haben und hoffen, dass es jetzt gut geht, aber äh ja
So ungefähr, aber ja, also dieses, also man konnte sagt den, den Widerwillen spüren. So.
Und ich meine, was natürlich auch so, ich meine, mein Mitleid hielt sich so ein bisschen in Grenzen, weil ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt Berlin jetzt nicht,
mit dabei den Verhandlungen am Tisch gesessen hätte, ja,
und ja also weiß ich nicht, dass das fand ich doch so ein bisschen ja,
Menschlich verständlich, aber mein Gott, da fühlt man sich da manchmal schon ey, du bist der Bürgermeister, du bist hier ja auch ihr Zoll doch nicht
ja
Ja, das stimmt, das war schon so ein bisschen so eine kleine kleine lasche Nummer, die er da gefahren hat.
Ja, also das war, ja das war to Much. Äh so, ich weiß nicht. Ähm ja, also nach der.
Merkel ist ja an der Stelle finde ich schon eine Ausnahme.
Ja
Weil die kommt ja nicht so rüber. Und vor allem muss man ja auch mal zugute halten. Ihr war klar.
Das, also das ist eine Unterstellung jetzt, ne, aber das ist so ein bisschen mein Eindruck. Hier war das schon vorher klar, dass.
Das passieren muss. Und sie hat ja schon vor zwei Wochen.
Im Prinzip dieses Lied angefangen zu singen. Verklausuliert unter ja hier äh jetzt aber wirklich und jetzt mal wirklich besorgniserregend und hast nicht gesehen und so weiter. Das hätte sie ja nicht gesagt,
Wenn sie nicht auch schon wirklich besorgt wäre und das wird sie dann wahrscheinlich auch schon zwei Wochen vorher gewesen sein oder,
hat sie sich sozusagen diese Strategie gewählt, um dann letzten Endes auch den ganzen Landesfürsten, wie man immer so schön sagt, da auch keine Wahl mehr zu lassen als mitzuziehen, weil sie sich ja vorher immer quergelegt haben.
Und hast du diese Nummer mit ihrem Podcast mitbekommen, eigentlich ihrem sogenannten Podcast? Sie macht doch diesen Video-Podcast, diese Ansprache. Guckt natürlich kein Mensch.
Es passiert passiert mal wieder was Interessantes. Da hatte sie dann eben vor zwei Wochen eine Ansprache. Mit genau, was ich gerade gesagt habe. So ja und jetzt reißt euch mal zusammen und überhaupt und wenn wir jetzt nicht alle an einem Strang ziehen und überhaupt und die Kontakte,
wir jetzt beschränken. So das volle Ding. Dann hat sie eine Woche später noch einen rausgehalten und hat gesagt so ja.
Alles was ich letzte Woche eigentlich so gesagt habe, gilt eigentlich auch immer noch und weil das so ist, spiele ich jetzt einfach nochmal den Podcast von letzter Woche,
und dann kam nochmal der gleiche Teil von der letzten Woche. Das war wirklich auch so auf dem Punkt. Also.
Sagen, das war gut. Das war fast ja Royal äh das das sah äh ja das war.
Wir werden.
Und.
Wir werden sie noch vermissen.
Ja und.
Ich mein mir komischerweise ist es mir, aber ich, ich hatte gehört, dass da was mit dem Podcast
war, aber so richtig äh ist äh ihre Ansprache bei mir im medialen Rauschen so ein bisschen untergegangen, aber ja, Fakt ist.
Dass äh sich das jetzt mit eigentlich dem Zeitpunkt.
Deckt äh oder den Zeitpunkten deckt, die wir äh äh vorhin gesagt haben, wo man eigentlich hätte handeln müssen. Und das heißt halt nur, dass sie auch vor ja.
Vier Wochen
schon erkannt hat, dass es jetzt aber höchste Zeit ist und das heißt aber auch, dass selbst wenn du Kanzler in diesem Land bist und irgendwie ein Kanzler mit einem,
ewigen Track Record.
Ja, dass es dann trotzdem so einen Monat dauern kann, bis dann tatsächlich was passiert, ja?
Und ja da haben ganz sicherlich uns sagen liegt dann die Verantwortung tatsächlich bei den Ländern und man muss ja sagen nicht nur liegt's ja nicht nur.
Sagen jetzt von der von der Sachlage, sondern auch rechtlich bei den Ländern, weil die sind ja für Gesundheit.
Zuständig im Wesentlichen, die kann ich ja nicht einfach anweisen.
Jetzt äh ja tut dies oder tut das. Insofern muss man sagen haben das äh ja die Länderchefs eigentlich verbaselt.
Eigentlich hätten's die Länder, stationär jetzt gucken, welcher von den Länderchefs auch schon mal vor vier Wochen getrommelt hat.
Und vor vier Wochen war es wirklich unübersehbar, wenn ich mir so den den Grafen. Ich habe den die ganze Zeit vor Augen so,
hätte auch schon vor zwölf Wochen hätte man auch schon Alarm schlagen können. Vor sechs Wochen und vor vier Wochen war's eigentlich.
Ja, hätte es allen klar sein müssen und das wäre der Zeitpunkt gewesen zu handeln. Auch.
Haben wir den Alarm geschlagen? Haben wir den Alarm geschlagen?
Wir haben gesagt, die Zahlen sind beunruhigend.
Wir haben immer gesagt äh R über eins geht nicht und
äh wir haben gesagt so, ja, das geht noch irgendwie ein bis drei Monate so gut,
So und dann jetzt ist es so ungefähr war es so anderthalb Monate glaube ich her, als wir das gesagt haben. Dass das noch gut geht und wir haben äh zugesagt, es kann aber jederzeit
Plötzlich abheben. So.
Und wir haben gesagt, Weihnachten wird's ungemütlich.
Ja, das äh kann auch hinhauen. Aber wir wollen es ja auch nicht als Propheten feiern lassen, sondern einfach nur ein bisschen ähm ja, vielleicht auch mal überlegen, was man noch noch besser machen kann.
Also und sagen, wir haben's gewusst, die Regierung hat's gewusst oder zumindest die Bundesregierung hat's gewusst,
Landesregierung dürften's eigentlich auch gewusst haben
aber wie gesagt so ähm mehr Fakten sind in der Politik halt dann auch nicht immer so das ausschlaggebende.
Eben.
Ich will's mal ein bisschen drehen und vielleicht mal eine eine Lanze äh brechen oder zumindest ist das so ein bisschen auch so meine Wahrnehmung, inwiefern ich da jetzt ins äh Schwarze treffe, kannst mir ja dann gleich erzählen, aber,
Ich denke welche Maßnahmen du auch immer beschließt.
Du musst natürlich nicht nur die Notwendigkeit davon sehen, sondern du musst ja auch quasi diese kollateralschäden sehen,
Und auch ich habe in meinem Umfeld Leute, denen ich einfach, also die mir matisch und intellektuell äh noch weit voraus sind, ja.
Trotzdem auch eine gewisse Skepsis an den Tag legen
Jetzt nicht hier so Telegram-Kanal, Schwubler, äh Demo, Himopaten, Wahnsinn und irgendwie äh die Welt wird verchiptmäßig, sondern eben ein.
Wie soll ich denn das sagen? Vielleicht diffuses Freiheitsgefühl auch.
Ähm unter Beschuss sehen, dass äh
quasi eigentlich auch so den eigenen Menschenverstand so ein bisschen das eigene Verhalten, bisschen abspricht, Maßnahmen ergriffen werden, die äh gesellschaftliche, langfristige, gesellschaftliche Kollateralschäden mit sich bringt.
Trifft vor allem natürlich so diese freiheitliche Alternativszene ja äh
die Künstler et cetera Leute, die ohnehin sagen wir mal in einen eigenen Freiräumen.
Leben und ein bisschen weiter entfernt sind eigentlich von dieser strikten Ordnung der Gesellschaft, um so ein bisschen alternatives Ding machen und die natürlich jetzt sehen,
durch diese starke Konzentration auf der Gesellschaft, so auf jetzt müssen die Regeln durchgesetzt werden, äh quasi unterm Bus geraten,
weil in ihrer alternativen Einnahmequellen wegbrechen und äh andere Freiheiten genommen werden und das macht die halt auch so ein bisschen wild,
Das ist natürlich so ein Punkt, der der da noch mit reinkommt. Das ist das eine, das andere ist, das soll natürlich auch wirklich hier
ich meine, das haben wir ja auch schon rauf und runter diskutiert zu dieser ganzen Verschwörungsfreunde.
Ja die jetzt einfach auch hinter allem irgendwas sehen wollen.
Ja, die auch überhaupt nicht mehr zu belehren sind, um mit Fakten auch überhaupt nicht zu beladen sind, die auch zu so einer Eskalation der Gewalt führen. Ich meine, wir hatten jetzt Brandanschläge,
im Kleinen, ne? Aber fand immerhin statt so Mototop-Cocktails auf RKI-Gebäude und äh Morddrohungen und was nicht alles, das kann sich natürlich noch weiter auch beschleunigen dadurch. Das sind glaube ich Dinge, die in dieser politischen Bewertung.
Auch noch eine Rolle spielen.
Nur mittlerweile wissen wir, weil wissen eigentlich schon seit langem, dass äh je früher.
Je härter man auf die Bremse tritt, umso schneller kann man wieder Gas geben, ja? So,
und ja, wenn man's aber einfach zu lange laufen lässt, so ähm ja, dann.
Man halt Stadt vielleicht dann einen Monat hat man dann halt drei Monate und dann außerdem so eine Zwischenphase wo also ich muss sagen,
Ich habe mir halt trotz auch der niedrigen Zahlen so im,
Juli und August äh war ich trotzdem im Corona Modus die ganze Zeit auch als die Zahlen niedrig waren. Ich habe zwar ja hier und da äh bisschen mehr dann gemacht, als es möglich war,
Aber grundsätzlich so war da nichts mit unbeschwert in der Zeit. Und wenn man jetzt dieses sagen,
je härter und je kürzer äh je härter und je früher, desto kürzer, so bis zum,
Ende durchdenkt, äh so, dann äh kommt man zu was, was auf das ich gestern gestoßen äh wurde oder
ja eigentlich vorher schon mal gehört hatte, aber ähm was sich entweder ja Zero Covit oder Total Surpreshen.
So, das sind so die beiden Stichworte und äh ja äh und mittlerweile,
Beziehungsweise ist mir dann erstmal aufgefallen, dass das aber bei uns immer für unmöglich gehalten wurde von vornherein, ja,
Szenario, nee, also irgendwie auf null äh äh runter oder ausgerottet, äh, kriegen wir das nicht. Das ist.
Unvorstellbar. Wir müssen's halt irgendwie nur auf also im besten Fall können wir hoffen, dass auf einigermaßen niedrigem Niveau zu managen, sodass es unser Gesundheitssystem nicht über.
Der Impfstoff kommt, der uns dann alle bef.
Der Impfstoff kommt. Genau, das war so irgendwie die die Strategie und irgendwie habe ich das auch, muss ich sagen, tatsächlich nie so hinterfragt, wobei äh meine Vorstellung, ich habe mich halt.
Immer in China so ein bisschen orientiert. Ich habe halt, weil China, die waren die ersten, da habe ich hatte ich die Zahlen gesehen, da habe ich halt gesehen, wie das gelaufen ist und bin eigentlich davon ausgegangen, dass das bei uns auch so läuft wie in China,
ja. Warum? Also weil ja, das war sozusagen das Modell
Leider muss man heute sagen, es ist bei uns nicht so gelaufen wie in China, sondern was die Chinesen halt anders gemacht haben. Die sind halt am Ball geblieben bis sie die Zahlen,
Rigo Ros auf einstellig runterhacken und haben dann auch nicht locker gelassen. So, ja.
Wir haben gesagt, ach ja wir statt irgendwie einstellige Zahlen, dass bei einem Land, ja wie China. Äh wir erlauben uns mal.
Ja, hundertmal so hohe Institzen im Land, wie China und machen trotzdem auf. Ja.
So und ja, das sei ja auch so zwei Monate lang so aus, als wenn wir irgendwie damit durchkommen.
Aber ja, seit drei Monaten sieht es halt nicht mehr so aus, äh, dass wir damit durchkommen und ähm.
Verstehe ich dich richtig, dass du Zero Cowit, also quasi dieses, wir rotten das jetzt einfach mal aus. Ähm quasi so als politisches Ziel.
Für einen wünschenswerten Weg sehen würdest, einfach weil hohe Ziele heißt auch große Erfolge.
Ich persönlich würde es vorziehen so, einen harten äh,
Monat zu haben, so oder meinetwegen auch ja zwei krasse Wochen. Ähm.
Und dann auf und auf Nummern runterzukommen, wohnen halbwegs normales Leben wieder möglich ist, statt.
Ja jetzt ich mein wie oft wollen wir das Spiel dann noch wiederholen? Wir werden sehen
wie das diesmal ausläuft. Ich hab kein gutes Gefühl jetzt bei dieser Welle gerade. Also wir haben die Hoffnung, wenn alles gut läuft, dass wir so irgendwie mit einem blauen Auge davon kommen, aber es wird weh tun,
definitiv weh tun und es werden sagt ich rechne damit mindestens tausend Leute mehr sterben, die halt nicht hätten sterben müssen und äh vielleicht,
mehrere tausend und wir werden wahrscheinlich zweihunderttausend, dreihunderttausend mehr infizierte haben,
jetzt durch diese Welle äh äh kommen so und ähm wie andere Sache ist.
Wir haben noch keinen Impfstoff. Es gehen zwar alle davon aus, auch ich glaube daran, dass
einen Impfstoff geben wird, aber wir wissen nicht, wie wirksam der sein wird, wie oft wir neu impfen
müssen so wie das Virus sich vielleicht verändert, wird es halt auch so, ich sage mal, indem ich wie eine Grippe und kommt dann immer erstmal saisonal und
Ähm so äh ja, das wissen wir halt halt alles äh noch nicht und wenn es aber jetzt,
eine Krankheit bleibt, die halt um so viel tödlicher ist wie die Grippe, die dann jedes Jahr wiederkommt und so und so viele Leute dahin rafft, ja?
Was wahrscheinlich nicht der Fall sein wird aber ja könnte es sogar sein,
dass das der einzige Aussieg ist, das andere Ding ist so, ist auch die Frage, okay.
Warum.
Klappt's bei uns nicht, was in China funktioniert hat, in Australien, in Neuseeland, in Südkorea und in einem Haufen afrikanischer Länder. Äh so nämlich tatsächlich,
dem äh äh ja Zero äh äh Kowid nahezu kommen in Neuseeland ist es so, da gibt's zwar wir haben mir das extra nochmal angeguckt, ähm.
Da gab's in den letzten vierzehn Tagen genau eine Übertragung innerhalb der Bevölkerung. Alle anderen Fälle waren Leute, die eingereist sind,
äh die man getestet hat und in der Infektion gefunden hat
und deswegen in Quarantäne. Also deswegen sind die Zahlen in den ganzen Ländern nicht wirklich null, wenn man sich die offiziellen Zahlen anguckt, weil äh dort halt Leute einreisen, die dann mit Kowit
festgesetzt werden und Carantinisiert werden. So ist es. Die Situation in diesen Ländern, so. Jetzt war natürlich, ja, das sind Inseln und
Australien, kleine Bevölkerungsdichte und asiatische Länder, die haben eine ganz andere Kultur und so.
Ja äh so das das stimmt alles und das.
Aber äh ja ich ich sehe trotzdem jetzt noch nicht.
Ja, ich meine, was ist denn das für ein Argument? Die haben eine andere Kultur. Das heißt doch, dass wir quasi die falsche Kultur haben, was das betrifft so, also da müssen wir halt sozusagen kulturellen Wandel auch einleiten, dass wir eben auch eine passende Kultur am Start haben. So,
heißt ja nicht, dass es nicht geht. Ich meine, an Masken haben wir uns ja mittlerweile auch gewöhnt so. Ich denke, äh mittlerweile auch in einem Maße, dass wenn sagen wir mal jetzt in fünf Jahren hier dann vielleicht dieser Virus
wirklich kein Thema mehr ist, ja. Klopf auf Holz, ja? Und dann ist aber so Erkältungswelle und dann wirst du Leute in der im Supermarkt sehen, die dann so eine scheiß Maske tragen.
Und keinen kümmert's.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Und äh kultureller Wandel ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer schnell zu machen, aber ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, als ob wir uns das groß.
Auswählen können. Also ja also ich stimm dir zu, ich sehe auch nicht ein.
Dass man da jetzt so ein äh Fatalismus einfach als Status Quo akzeptieren muss, mit ja ist halt so,
Weil die ganze Situation hatten wir so noch nicht. Und es ist ja absehbar, dass es das einfach noch eine ganze Menge kostet. Es kostet uns.
Geld, es kostet uns Wirtschaftsleistung, es kostet uns irgendwie eine Menge Spaß.
Das kostet uns Lebenszeit äh sowohl jetzt.
Wenn man nicht stirbt als eben auch Lebenszeit äh Verkürzung und macht die Sache nicht besser, ne? Auf der anderen Seite ist es schon klar, ist jetzt irgendwie kein deutsches Problem, sondern es ist hal.
So ein europäisches, westliches Problem im Wesentlichen, ja? Man kann jetzt lange darüber diskutieren, ob jetzt Australien und Neuseeland,
per se noch so westliche Welt ist oder ob sie nicht eigentlich schon sehr viel mehr äh von der asiatischen mitgeprägt sind.
Das ist nun mal auch deren primäre Tradingpartner und da ist in den letzten hundert Jahren nicht nichts passiert, sondern die stehen da sozusagen äh haben da andere Vorbilder als jetzt ausgerechnet uns,
die sie uns ja eigentlich am wenigsten kennen. Ja, also Zirokovic, ich bin dabei.
Ich will jetzt gut, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass es jetzt sagen die Silver Bullet oder die Lösung äh ist äh unbedingt ähm oder die beste Lösung, sagen wir.
Habe ich den schönen Spruch Pavel dreihundert Prozent angestrebt, hundertfünfzig Prozent erreicht, ja? Also wenn man sozusagen
sich hohe Ziele setzt, dann kann man eben auch weit kommen. Und äh wenn man eigentlich von vornherein aufgibt und sagt so, ja es funktioniert ja eh nicht, dann kann man's halt eigentlich auch gleich bleiben lassen. Und
Das äh ist insofern wär's mal ganz sinnvoll, sowas zu haben, andererseits
falls ich jetzt nicht, was uns bevorsteht, also wir werden jetzt wahrscheinlich die
wissenschaftlich geprägte Frau Merkel in absehbarer Zeit durch irgendein Handel ersetzen und ob's dann besser wird, weiß ich nicht.
Ja? Wahrscheinlich ja eher nicht oder sie tritt nochmal an, weil irgendwie ja.
Kein passender Nachfolger da irgendwie, ich mache das jetzt einfach nochmal, würde ich sofort nehmen.
Ja, ich glaube, sie würde auch, also ich, ja, äh ich mein.
Ja, aber ich hätte lieber so eine, so eine äh Enddreißiger Anfang, vierziger äh Frau irgendwie an der Spitze so wie Neuseeland, sowas wie ich auch haben. Wando.
Das ja, dass wir schon näher ich meine das das Hauptproblem äh natürlich in um in Europa jetzt,
sowas wie Zerokovic äh zu fahren, muss das geht nur gesamteuropäisch. Ja, wir haben einfach so viele Verflechtungen und das ist auch eigentlich ein Versagen von von Europa, aber,
ja ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen und,
wenn man nach, ich meine nach China guckt, was die halt äh machen, werden das, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung schon erwähnt, die haben da einfach mal wegen einem Fall eine komplette Stadt durchgetestet mit
irgendwie zwei Millionen Tests gemacht, die nach eins Komma zwei Millionen Tests glaube ich, die dann nach zwei Tagen alle ausgewertet waren, nur weil in einer Region einen Kowit-Fall aufgetreten ist, ja,
Und ähm ich meine, das hatten wir auch schon mal als theoretisches Szenario,
diskutiert, warum testet man nicht einfach die gesamte Bevölkerung durch. Ich meine, das wäre auch ein Ding, man macht einen vierzehntägigen Shutdown,
und in den vierzehn Tagen testet man die gesamte Bevölkerung durch, ja?
Gut, die Kapazitäten dürfen wir so nicht äh haben, aber ähm.
Nee, aber äh im Moment nicht, aber äh so ich denke mal.
Wir haben mit äh es gibt halt neue Tests, man kann mit Pooling arbeiten, äh man könnte die Kap
ja oder weiter hochfahren, bisher sind sie halt nur
weil das halt im Wesentlichen alles privatwirtschaftlich stattfindet, halt nur so hochgefahren worden, das kann ich auch verstehen, äh wie sie halt, ja, wenn sie sagen, ausgelastet sind, aber mindestens ja zu zwei Drittel oder so ausgelastet sind. Also wir haben noch ein bisschen Überkapazitäten, aber.
Ja, und mir fehlen auch noch ein paar kreative Lösungen. Was ist zum Beispiel hier mit diesen ganzen äh Tests an äh in Wasserwerken, ja? Also,
das ist ja nun in anderen Ländern auch durchaus zum Einsatz gekommen, kann er keine Zahlen nennen. Gut, da gab's jetzt auf jeden Fall Experimente in Holland, jetzt taugt das Land auch nicht gerade äh unbedingt als Vorbild, aber auch äh so ein so ein,
so ein Monitoring auf der Basis, habe ich jetzt auch nicht gesehen und vor allem wissen wir ja.
Haben zumindest die Berichte, die wir uns damals angeschaut haben, dass sozusagen äh gesagt,
Mit Vorlauf, also man hat sozusagen schon vor dem Ausbruch das gesehen, weil die Leute quasi den Virus schon äh tragen, ausscheiden und dann äh konnte man das eben tatsächlich im Abwasser messen,
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, wie es da weitergegangen ist. Hm, vielleicht äh sind die vorhin schon Probleme gestoßen, vielleicht ist es auch einfach noch nicht ausreichend äh verfolgt worden. Und es ist in gewisser Hinsicht so ein bisschen wie mit dieser Energiewende. Bei der Wende dir heute anschaust.
Was Solartechnik an Energie für ein Energieproduktionsanteil in Deutschland hat.
Also stellenweise,
wir sind ja schon über weit über fünfzig Prozent gekommen im Sommer an manchen Tagen und und der Anteil ist jetzt um ein Vielfaches höher als vor zwanzig Jahren einem immer angeredet wurde, wie er jemals sein könnte.
Das hat eben dann einfach auch, dass einfach so ein bisschen der, da fehlt es einfach an Mut. Da fehlt es einfach an verrückte Sachen ausprobieren und crazy Projekte äh starten und vor allem auf,
auf auf voller Breite ran zu gehen, sowie sowie Tesla an das Problem Mobilität und regenerative Energie rangeht, so müsste man halt eigentlich auch an diesen Virus rangehen.
Das Problem ist natürlich speziell in der Politik in der Regel überall, wo das versucht wurde, sind die Leute äh dann sehr häufig ja,
auf die Nase gefallen, weil es sie ist nicht gut.
Gemanaged wurde. Ich sage nur Nürburgring. Stichwort zum Beispiel oder BER oder äh ja.
Andere größere Projekte, da sind wir da, wo man dann irgendwie rangegangen ist, so mit dem ja.
Ja gut, es sind aber einzelne Projekte, die es nicht funktioniert haben, aber so kollektiv einfach viele Ansätze auch parallel äh zu machen. Da kommen wir jetzt, glaube ich, im Vergleich mit Flughäfen nicht sehr weit.
Nee, aber sozusagen solche, ich sage mal, experimentellen Dinge macht sich natürlich in der Politik.
Besonders angreifbar und wir haben halt auch in der Politik so eine Skandalisierungskultur, die hier jetzt wahrscheinlich auch mit reingespielt hat. Ich meine, kann man ja äh jetzt
auch gerade sehen im Moment in den Medien die ganze Empörung aus verschiedensten Ecken, wo Leute,
zum Teil zu Recht, die Maßnahmen anprangern, weil sie besonders davon betroffen sind und das ungerecht finden und so oder ist unlogisch und äh ja.
Und ihr schon vorhin sagt es ja ganz viele Leute, die das grundsätzlich sich da auf den Schlips getreten äh äh fühlen. Durch,
irgendwelche staatlichen Anordnungen oder Maßnahmen oder Verbote, äh die plötzlich neu da sind,
Und wie gesagt, die Politik mein,
man hat zwar oft den Eindruck, dass die Bürger nicht gehört werden, aber das stimmt manchmal, aber stimmt halt ganz oft äh auch nicht, sondern.
Gesagt, Leute wollen schon gewählt werden und die machen sich da schon teilweise krumm oder tun so, dass sie sich krumm machen oder.
Ja versuchen auf jeden Fall den Eindruck zu vermitteln, dass irgendwie äh sich krumm machen.
Na gut, wir machen uns äh nicht krumm, wir wollen auch nicht gewählt werden, wir wollen nur gehört werden,
Alles haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, aber auch ausreichend ausgereizt für heute, oder? Ein paar Wilder haben wir irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen, sonst habe ich irgendwie nur noch so äh Triviakram, den müssen wir ja irgendwie jetzt nicht weiter besprechen, glaube ich
Ähm.
Ich bin sagt eigentlich ja auch durch, was sagt denn deine Coronapan App eigentlich äh so, wenn du die aufmachst.
Meine Krone waren äh was hat meine Chrona-Warne-Frage? Ich gucke mal kurz. Ähm bin runter auf zwei Begegnungen mit niedrigem Risiko.
Ich auch, aber ich hatte auch nicht mehr, hattest du mehr als zwei.
Ich hatte auch schon mal mehr, ich glaube ich war mal bis zu äh fünf. Und das ist schon bemerkenswert, weil ich eigentlich nicht viel.
Mich nicht so viel jetzt unter äh Leute begebe, klar ich bin auch mal draußen, man geht an Leuten vorbei, Pipapo ähm Supermärkte und so, aber.
Wir wissen ja, wie viele Leute diese äh App auch am Ende nicht verwenden, beziehungsweise nicht verwenden, um dann auch wirklich ihren positiven Test
abzugeben und dann eben noch in den letzten zwei Wochen und dann müssen sie auch noch an mir vorbeigegangen sein und ich muss genau in diesen fünf Minuten Zeitfenster, wo sie mir nah waren, auch äh
Empfang angehabt haben. Von daher ist da so eine gewisse Unwahrscheinlichkeit äh drin und da fand ich dann so Zahlen mit äh fünf schon relativ.
Ja
Also ich habe, wie gesagt, zwei und äh was mich halt so ein bisschen nervt ist natürlich, dass ich nicht die geringste Ahnung habe, wann äh das passiert ist.
Hast du denn schon mein Gespräch mit Henning Tillmann nachhören können? Da hab ich ja
hier alles äh lang und breit ausgekäse, was wir da alles äh furchtbar und falsch finden und was man noch besser machen könnte und da stimme ich dir total zu, also diese zeitliche Auswertung oder generell
dieser Mangel an Einschätzungshilfe, ja? Das das ist sozusagen etwas, was äh da auch noch zu langsam läuft,
aber schauen wir mal wie es weitergeht. Ähm, ich will jetzt auch nicht alles schlecht machen,
auf jeden Fall sollten wir vielleicht hier enden mit dem Wunsch des ja auch alle.
Mitmacht und äh ich hoffe, dass äh Podcast hören euch auch schon durch den November bringt.
Äh ich habe schon ganz viel produziert dieses Jahr, bin schon weit über meinen äh Produktionslimit des letzten Jahres gekommen.
Das ist jetzt hier schon fast die hundertfünfte Sendung, die ich irgendwie dieses Jahr mache, also irgendwie weit über zwo Komma drei Sendungen pro Woche.
Letztes Jahr habe ich noch nicht mal auf hundert gekommen.
Aber na ja, jetzt habe ich ja eh nichts anderes zu tun im November, also wird's wahrscheinlich so weitergehen. Gut.
Machen wir Schluss, wa? Gut, Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, äh bis dann und ich denke, wir werden.
Ja, passt auf euch auf.
Genau, wir werden nächste Woche dann auch wieder ein äh Update machen. Äh merke, solange Corona Wickly, wirklich Wickli ist, ist es ist dringend.
Tragen wir äh hoffentlich alle dazu bei, dass wir diese Sendung irgendwann auch wieder einstellen können. Aber noch ist nicht so weit. Okay. Dann sagen wir tschüss und bis.
Tschüs.